[Applaudissements]
un budget de la culture en hausse 3,2
milliards en hausse de 8% par rapport à
2020 sans compter les 1,6 milliards
alloués pas à la culture dans le plan de
relance
commençons par nous réjouir oui la
culture est une dimension essentielle de
la relance une dimension cruciale du
monde d'après mais avant d'envisager le
monde d'après nous a fallu sauver celui
d'aujourd'hui
le secteur culturel principalement le
monde de la création si fragile aurait
pu s'effondrer lorsque la crise a frappé
les différents dispositifs transversaux
le chômage partiel les pgm est aussi
l'année blanche pour les intermittents
et les différentes fonds de soutien ou
d'urgence mises en place par les
collectivités locales ont permis de
maintenir la majeure partie du monde
culturel à flot nos amortisseurs sociaux
combiné au dispositif exceptionnel ont
permis de faire survivre l'exception
culturelle française aux chocs terry de
cette pandémie mondiale
mais lorsqu'on interroge la diversité du
monde culturel
nous constatons que la situation est
critique nous avons affaire à des
structures en apnée placé dans une
situation de fragilité extrême en 2020
les perspectives pour 2021 sont sombres
la situation sanitaire comme la crise
sociale qui guette place le monde de la
culture dans une incertitude extrême
chacun retient son souffle jongle avec
les différents dispositifs pour
construire une saison culturelle sans
perspectives claires alors cette crise a
été révélatrice révélatrice de fortes
inégalités aussi amplificatrice des
atouts et des travers de notre politique
culturelle
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins
2021 démontrera soit la résilience de
notre richesse culturelle soit la fin
d'un modèle le budget que vous nous
présenter madame la ministre
s'il est au rendez vous d'une relance
culturelle ambitieuse amplifie aussi un
certain nombre de travers dans notre
modèle pour le patrimoine tout d'abord
le budget le plus important de cette
mission avec près d'un milliard d'euros
pour 2021
nous nous réjouissons tout naturellement
de cet effort sans précédent vers le
monument de musées nos cathédrales la
préservation de ce patrimoine maintien
et enrichit le savoir faire unique et
non délocalisables de la conservation et
la mise en valeur historique je pense
notamment aux charpentiers tailleur de
pierre ébéniste restaurateur d'art qui
fonde une autre histoire cependant
lorsqu'on regarde le détail de cet
effort financier on s'aperçoit qu'il
bénéficie majoritairement grandes
institutions et monuments franciliens et
que les transferts aux collectivités
locales dans le budget de la culture
sont en baisse par rapport à 2020
de 20 millions du pin d'euros hors plan
de relance il ya ici en filigrane une
vision trop centralisatrice de la
culture patrimoniale qui n'est pas celle
des écologistes pour la création ensuite
nous avons également un budget en hausse
de 3,8 pour cent s'établissant à plus de
880 millions d'euros il nous faut là
encore nous en réjouir ainsi que des
dispositifs transversaux qui ont permis
comme je le disais tout à l'heure la
survie de milliers de structure
mais la relance aurait pu être
l'occasion de faire émerger un autre
modèle de développement culturel on se
rend compte en dialoguant avec les
structures locales que cette relance
comme pour le patrimoine renforce encore
davantage notre centralisation plus on
s'éloigne de paris ou des grandes
métropoles plus la fragilité des
structures s'accentue il faut également
noter que cette relance s'appuie sur une
version très labellisé d'humaniste du
ministère il ya parfois des trous dans
la raquette et des petites structures
souvent associatives sont dans un état
de fragilité extrême risque de
disparaître et nous porterons des
amendements pour consolider ses réseaux
et ses petites structures
enfin je souhaite aborder la question
des festivals il n'y a en france qu'une
minorité des festivals qui bénéficie du
soutien du ministère de la culture 170
en 2019 sur les 6000 festival commence
notre pays
ce différentiel s'explique
principalement par une méconnaissance
mutuelle entre les deux mondes qui
s'ignorent
parfois ce décalage entre les
différentes réalités culturelles et la
réalité des pratiques toujours en
mouvement et protéiforme ci est déjà
inquiétante normal veut prendre une
tournure dramatique en temps de crise
avec la fragilisation de centaines de
festivals qui font vivre leur territoire
et qui risque la disparition nous
espérons que la deuxième édition des
états généraux des festivals qui se
tiendront trois tons de gauche permettra
au ministère de prendre conscience de la
grande diversité de ces milieux il faut
également noter que depuis plusieurs
années de grands groupes rachète ou
prennent des participations dans un
ensemble de festivals dans une logique
d'intégration verticale et maîtrise de
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur parmi
les festivals de musiques actuelles dans
l'étude varrault fest où il est montré
que les grands groupes représentent 14%
des festivals et pèse 90% de la
billetterie ces progressions du marché
du capital dans un univers créatif
jusque là plutôt réservé préserver de
sévérité mercantile doit nous alerter
puisque la culture pour nous doit rester
aux mains de ceux qui la font vivre et
c'est le rôle de l'état de s'en assurer
en conclusion madame la ministre nous
saluons la forêt elle constitue dans ce
budget la culture sa vision ne sombre
encore plutôt conservatrice visant plus
le retour à l'avant crise qu'une relance
culturelle qui aurait pu élargir et
diversifier notre modèle nous voterons
toutefois ce budget tout en espérant une
attention particulière à nos amendements
je vous remercie
[Musique]